meine sehr geehrten damen und jan
soldatinnen und soldaten
ich darf mich nun von ihnen
verabschieden am freitag wechselt der
streitkräfte kommandant generalleutnant
franz reißner in den verdienten
ruhestand in der grazer belgier kaserne
findet aus diesem anlass ein großer
festakt statt für
verteidigungsministerin klaudia tanner
ein tag zum feiern aus drei gründen
gesprochen hat der
erfolgreiche abschluss seiner offiziers
und kommandanten karriere die
ihresgleichen sucht und drittens ist es
der beginn eines
derzeit genug bringen sollte um 46
dienstjahre revue passieren zu lassen
was sagt man zu so einem anlass ist die
letztlich aus
dass es einen am herzen liegt öffentlich
zu sagen
geworden ist es eine gute halbe stunde
voller geschichten und erinnerungen für
den ein oder anderen humorvollen moment
sagt dann der steirische landeshauptmann
hermann schützenhöfer sie haben soldaten
ein großes lebenswerk vollbracht
dafür danke ich ihnen
seit des landes sind sie aus dekoriert
wir haben das große goldene ehrenzeichen
gegeben
vielmehr rubine
[Gelächter]
und und ihre frau
noch nicht ganz verteidigungsministerin
klaudia tanner verleiht dem namen von
bundespräsident alexander van der bellen
den jubilar das große goldene
ehrenzeichen für verdienste um die
republik
[Applaus]
[Musik]
alles gute
viel glück und gesundheit
[Musik]